أرى أشياء تحدث هنا
لم أكن أعتقد أنها ممكنة ، وأعتقد أن الأمر
كله عبارة عن حديث سيناتور أمريكي
احتفظت بالحق في تغيير المسار
[موسيقى] [
موسيقى]
[موسيقى]
أجنبية ،
ما أريده هو علاقة من
الجانب العسكري
يمكننا بيع أسلحة إلى المملكة العربية السعودية
أسلحة أمريكية للمساعدة في الدفاع ضد
أعداء مشتركين. أريد أن أستمر في تدريب
ضباطك ومدارسنا على
برنامج تبادل للأفراد العسكريين
وأريد ترقية العلاقة
عسكريًا وأود الحصول على بعض
الاتفاق مع المملكة العربية السعودية  سأكون
مؤيدًا لاتفاقية الدفاع المتبادل ،
ولا أعرف ما إذا كانت لدينا
الأصوات لصالحها ، ولكن هناك اتفاق من
شأنه أن يجعل المملكة العربية السعودية أقرب إلى حليف في الناتو
وأقل شبهاً بخصم
[موسيقى]
أجنبي [
موسيقى]
[موسيقى]
فرصة  وتوخي الحذر ، نعم
نحن هنا للحصول على فرصة ، فهذه هي
أفضل فرصة رأيتها منذ عقود
لترقية العلاقة
[موسيقى]
أجنبية